il marche sur les traces des oiseaux
versailles et ou plutôt des volatiles
qui ont élu domicile à la pièce d'eau
des suisses en période hivernale elle
abrite de nombreux spécimens des espèces
que l'association nature et vous décide
de faire découvrir aux ornithologues en
herbe armés de jumelles et de chaussures
de marche
je sais qu'ils sont présents d'autres
personnes faisant remarquer aussi c'est
le fuligule morillon et le fuligule
milouin sont des espèces de canards
j'y connais rien en fait je les connais
pas du tout et ça m'intéresse de pouvoir
les reconnaître un petit peu c'est très
intéressant ça permet de mettre des noms
sur les
mes animaux qu'on voit mais là les
oiseaux et puis d'apprendre un peu leurs
moeurs comprendre un peu mieux fuligules
grèbes huppés ou signe des oiseaux d'eau
écologiquement dépendant des milieux
humides
l'association a décidé de les faire
connaître grâce à cette promenade d'une
heure et demie une initiative qu'elle
conduit pour la première fois les deux
objectifs de l'association sont
effectivement de sensibiliser les gens à
la protection de l'environnement
c'est quelque chose qui nous touche nous
touche beaucoup et puis la deuxième
chose c'est de faire découvrir aux
participants qu'à côté de chez eux ou en
bas de chez eux il y à des espèces qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de reconnaître et
qui ont des choses à nous apprendre
un de nos objectifs aussi c'est de
montrer aux gens qu'ils ont de quoi
s'émerveiller autour de même des espèces
qui sont très commune finalement on peut
retrouver cet émerveillement juste en
ouvrant les yeux en observant ce qui
nous entoure le patrimoine naturel de
versailles enfin révélé prochaine balade
programmé par l'association le 23 avril
au départ de la cathédrale saint louis
là où mich le faucon crécerelle une
autre espèce méconnu